[Music]
Trump has said of a Secretary of State
we are always on the same wavelength as
you'll see in my interview with Mike
Pompeo that's apparent we begin our
conversation today discussing Iran and
his predecessor John Kerry's wildly
destructive communications with the
world's largest state sponsor of terror
here's part 1 of my interview with
Secretary of State State Mike Pompeo mr.
secretary thanks so much for joining us
we really really appreciate it to be
with you
Iran in the news Brian hook your special
envoy saying you know we want to deal
with Iran but a treaty with Iran Iranian
leaders no-go they're like we don't want
any we don't want any dealings for the
United States at this point what's going
on
president Trust has been very clear
since the time he was running for office
that the arrangement that the previous
administration put in place was bad for
America frankly bad for the world and so
I and Brian are working to get Iran to
behave like a normal nation right stop
being the world's largest state sponsor
of terror stop launching missiles
through proxies stop attacking our
embassies and consulates when we get
those basic things in place our
president rumps are made very clear I
would love Ron to rejoin the community
of nations but their revolutionary zeal
causes them to be a bad actor and they
need to shape up and if they do we'll
get it right
well again you you and John Kerry have
gone back and forth on this former
Secretary of State Barack Obama has met
four times with Iranian leadership and
you guys criticize saying that's not
appropriate given you know it's a can't
have to track foreign policy here but he
responded by saying there's nothing
unusual let alone unseemly or
inappropriate about former diplomats
meeting with foreign counterparts
Secretary of State Kissinger had done it
for decades with Russia and China
what is unseemly and unprecedented for
the podium the State Department to be
hijacked for political theatrics
secretary Kerry can't seem to get off
the stage and you have to when I'm the
former secretary I'll get off every
previous former secretaries done that -
it's one thing to meet with your
counterpart it's another thing to do
with secretary Kerry Wendy Sherman
Ernest Moniz frankly the whole gang
has done which is to actively seek to
undermine what President Trump is trying
to achieve it's okay to talk to them but
you have to be working for America
working for American foreign policy and
they're not there they're working for
the foreign policy that is theirs not
the one that belongs to the United
States our own dana perino last week had
carry on and he did not deny that he
wanted to basically tell the Iranians
that whether he told they want to wait
it out for the next administration I
think everybody in the world is sitting
around talking about waiting out
President Trump at what point does the
administration pursue some type of legal
action against former secretary Kerry
and others from the former
administration you know well I'll leave
the legal action to others I'm trying to
execute America's foreign policy and
they are not only unhelpful but they are
acting in ways that are harmful to
achieving what's best for the American
people and that's that's my criticism
stop it let it go you had your day we
think you fundamentally got it wrong
with Iran and we're trying to make it
right for America and reducing the
refugee number that's caused great
consternation it's another issue that
President Trump campaigned on extreme
vetting security for our country down to
30,000 next fiscal year Bob Menendez big
fan of the administration called it
cruel and short-sighted human rights
first another group
it's an abdication mr. secretary of our
humanity your response America is the
most generous nation in the history of
civilization it it always has been and
it continues to be under President Trump
we want to get it right for the American
people we've taken in over 4 million
legal permanent residents in the last
almost two decades now we continue to
take in more people than most countries
in the rest of the world but we got to
get the security piece right we got to
make sure that we allow those who are in
most trouble most harm's way to be taken
care of in the best place to take care
of them nearer their own country those
are those are not heartless things those
are things that are kind and caring and
decent it's the way we ought to treat
our fellow human beings and it's what we
in the Trump administration are
committing to do what is this
administration say to
the Christian refugees who feel many of
them abandoned in free many years
predating this administration in Syria
in Iraq and beyond they can't go to
these camps because they're afraid of
going to the camps how do we reach them
how do we get some of them into the
country so it's an important and
difficult challenge we want to bring in
all those who are most in trouble in our
having the most difficulty in the places
in which they reside vice president
pence has made this a real priority to
ensure that Christians are being treated
fairly and equitably in our processes
we've seen some of these issues in these
camps rest assured that the State
Department's working to make sure that
Christians are not being mistreated
prosecuted persecuted or treated in any
way that's unfair as they try to make
their way into the United States of
America the u.s. Commission on
International Religious Freedom lists
China and Saudi Arabia right now one and
I think Saudi Arabia is number three the
worst violators of human rights I was
thinking about this yesterday because
think of the old Soviet Union and
President Reagan who both of us admire
so much we didn't do that really heavily
engaged trade with the Soviet Union not
just because of nukes but because of
what they were doing on human rights so
how do we justify this huge trading
relationship with Saudi Arabia in China
given how we treat than North Korea in a
place like Cuba seems like there's
selective treatment of human rights
violation so it's always the case when
you're trying to advocate for America's
interest that you have to weigh the
relative concerns and it is the case
that each country presents its own
situation what I think we've been
incredibly consistent on is making sure
that we identify we call out these
concerns I've done it with respect to
China I've done it with respect to every
place we find religious minorities being
mistreated we held the first-ever
religious ministerial in the very room
in which we're sitting here it was quite
an occasion people from nearly every
religion than 80 delegations this
administration is taking religious
freedom all around the world in China
and other places in China entertain
Christian churches crosses being smashed
churches driven underground pastors
being imprisoned
and you know what we have to talk about
my good friend President Xi it's just
it's it's it's it's heartbreaking to so
many of us who care about religious
liberty and I know this is an
administration priority but what do you
do what leverage do we have with China
at this point other than what we're
doing now with trade Laura I'm
comfortable talk about China in other
contexts too it presents a myriad of
opportunities but lots of challenges you
speak of one this is a non transparent
government it is still a very
centralized government it treats our
intellectual property horley it treats
its religious minorities horribly in
each of these cases we have
opportunities you've seen what the
president's doing with trade to try and
make it fair and reciprocal what we're
asking of China is to behave in a way
that if they want to be a power that
they want to be on the global stage they
have to operate in the way that global
leaders have for so often and frankly as
you point out in the religious dimension
they've not done that we talk a lot
about this big tech and the relationship
between big tech and this administration
whether it's adversarial but Google
specifically in China assisting Google
and developing an app to further censor
free expression and the ability of
Chinese citizens to get information any
thoughts on that how a US company
obviously huge global company to assist
China in that oppression of free
expression Laura it is personally and
professionally troubling to me when
American companies behave one way here
and another way when they're dealing
with China it gets at the core problem
that President Trump is trying to
address which is that China doesn't
permit American investors to invest on
the same terms that Chinese companies
can invest here joint ventures the the
list is long of the non-reciprocal
relationship the president's trying to
balance that and when we get that right
when government gets that right we can
then force American companies to behave
under that set of rules I want I want
every company including global Giants to
treat American citizens as well as they
treat the government's some of these
despotic regimes and yet they hit they
hit the administration President Trump
the day after a couple days after the
election yet Sergey Brin up there got
brilliant guy brilliant people
but criticizing this administration's
immigration policy when they're
assisting despotic to tell it to
basically you know obviously communist
regimes overseas but Trump's the threat
I think we have American foreign policy
on the right track on each of the
dimensions that you're describing and
and and when we get get it right when we
when we ultimately see the end result of
president Trump's efforts I see you I
think you'll see many of these things in
a place that America has not seen before